and you're getting into new spaces first
of all new worlds with Starfield but
also new I saw the TV show you're
working on
uh
on Fallout
with Amazon what's that like worlds that
you created in the digital realm
becoming going on the screen yeah people
asked you know I can remember 10 years
ago after Fallout 3 was a hit you know
the movie Producers coming and hey we
think this would make a great movie
and taking a lot of meetings and I think
every you know most people would jump at
that like sweet and
I sort of paused and like I don't know
what is this gonna do
I felt like they're like synthesizing
about great people like well-known
creatives like you know it's gonna get
synthesized into this two-hour I don't
know I'm not
I'm not seeing the great thing here yet
so
you know I think the Advent of
television
in terms of what it's become you know in
nowadays with big budget TV series it
kind of came up again and met with
people and uh Jonathan Nolan and Lisa
Joy who do Westworld and I always
love the work he did uh writing
Interstellar and the dark like movies I
just got the Nolan's involved with this
yeah he's the yeah he's the he's the EP
and he's big Direct in the first
incredible yeah
and uh he he's the ep's directed the
first few episodes
um and and when I connected with him
uh Jonah was like Hey you know you're my
you're the person I want to do this so I
haven't met with people kept saying like
you know just
let me see if he wants to do it and I
was to my joy he was like oh yeah fall
three is one of my yeah sign me up there
was like no how do we get this done
and at that time he was sort of he was
at HBO and it was you know
we were trying to figure out it was put
a little pause on it
um and uh
you know got to visit the sets reading
scripts and things like that it's all
new to me
um but I
they're doing such an incredible job
like I think if you like this world you
are gonna be just blown away so cute
I've never made a TV show you know those
are all the best you know no one ever
does it uh wanting it to not be great
but they've just done their attention to
detail and obsessed there's obsessive
with what's on the screen
and the storytelling and how it looks
the whole the whole thing yeah I think
obsession is really uh a prerequisite
for greatness what they did uh HBO did
with Chernobyl
like the attention details and and he's
doing uh The Last of Us now that
showrunner if you really care and you
really put a lot of effort into the
details
I was stunned that they I mean
I don't want to spoil but when people
see it I think you'll just be like wow
it's the um the other thing we're
approaching it is very different where
when it was people would say want to
make a movie they wanted to you know
tell the story of Fallout 3 or then tell
the story of Fallout 4. and for this it
was
hey let's do something that exists in
the world of Fallout
it's not retelling a game story it's
basically you know an area of the map
and like let's tell a story here that
fits in the world that we have built
doesn't you know break any of the rules
can reference things in the games but
isn't a retelling of the games it exists
in the same world but is its own unique
thing so it adds to it while also people
who don't haven't played the games who
can't experience like how crazy cool
Fallout is
um can watch the series and so
yeah there's some similarities or
interesting differences between the
creation of a game and a TV show they
notice from the sort of story
perspective well for them you know it's
much more character driven like you can
do all these things with the world and
stuff that we already have
um
it's the main characters who they are
what their motivations are that
really is the engine
right there's no uh finding the right
actors to do those yeah because you're
not there's no interaction
there's no
um you don't get to enter that world
they have to do the work for you the
NPCs are on the show